hey everyone I'm Kristen Gill with how
to Hollywood and I have celebrity makeup
artist
Jill Powell with me today she has done
every demi lovato look that everyone has
ever loved thank you
tell us about what you're going to be
creating on me today so today I'm gonna
be showing you how to do one of our
recent performance looks today john demi
for her new single sorry not sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
so how are we gonna start i always start
with skin so we got a moisturize and get
her skin all prepped okay sounds good
alright so one of my secrets is I love
moisture serums what's great about these
is your skin absorbs it so you don't
have a lot of products thing on your
face so makes the makeup last longer so
I like to massage it in and this way you
can also feel the texture of the face
and anywhere that needs a little extra
life if you feel your skin there's not
it's not too slippery so your makeup
will stick to every yeah and it won't
slide off so Demi performs a lot so I
always want to make sure that it her
makeup stays on so this is something for
performance I'll skip moisturizer and
just do the moisture serum because
you'll find that you'll be more and
glowy yeah and my thing is glowing skin
because Demi performs a lot we always
need to make sure that the makeup stays
and if she sweats I want to make sure
that it's long-lasting so this is my
secret weapon and I go in with a brush
and just a really sheer layer that's all
you need
right on top of your moisturizer so I
like to mix a lot of foundation so you
can see I have all different colors and
all different actually textures as well
yeah I like to create like a normal
dimension on your face so instead of
doing one color all over I create
different dimensions so I start with
deeper tones on the forehead this one's
gonna be too deep for her skin so I'm
mixing it with a little bit of a lighter
color and I'm gonna start along the
forehead and by mixing I can really
create like the exact color that I want
in each area so I like the forehead to
be a little bit darker because where the
Sun naturally hits is the high plains of
your face
a little bit lighter towards the center
and blending it out so now that I have
our forehead done you can see it's a
little bit of a darker color I will also
take that deeper tone in the hollows of
her cheek right here so this kind of
just adds a base to the contour so now
that we have created the contours I'm
going to go in the lower part of the
face just on the outsides matching her
skin tone along the chin and then a
little bit lighter underneath her
contour area so just with foundation I'm
creating all these natural dimensions so
that you don't have to do a time with
other products with these are the
concealers they look really smooth they
have a tiny bit of luminosity and I
don't like to look dry under the eyes
when I do under the eyes I personally
like to so this one's going to be your
lighter one which is probably going to
match your tone but I also like to mix
in more of like a peachy tone because I
find that peach really corrects okay so
if you have a lot of Darkness if you
think of color theory so yellow and blue
make green so if you have a lot of Blues
under your eyes and you put a yellow
concealer you might get more of that
like greenish gray cast okay and it's
not really covering mm-hmm but you want
to like counteract that so the opposite
of blue is orange okay so that's gonna
if you lay orange on top of blue it
neutralizes yeah so a peach is a mixture
between pink and orange and yellow so
it's actually combating your blue your
green and your purple which are the
colors underneath your eyes so start
with my lighter tone and then I just mix
a tiny bit of peach and you had had it's
already covered but you had a tiny bit
of discoloration right here so I'm gonna
just go ahead and add that peach there
and again I'm pressing it I like to use
more of like a flat brush but not
completely flat so this one has a tiny
fluff to it and I just press it in and
then I'm gonna go in with that lighter
tone right on these inner corners a lot
of times on our self we forget that this
inner corner is really important so I
see a lot of people and they leave it
blank
that's what opens up the eyes
you want to make sure that that's nice
and bright and I'm pressing and kind of
sweeping so this is by NARS and it has
two really great contour colors and some
beautiful highlight yeah
and when I contour I like it to just be
really natural so I'm going to start out
I like to use more of like an angled
blush brush for me this really like hugs
the contours of the face at home I want
you to like feel for where your
cheekbone is and understand the the
anatomy of your face and where you know
where it is a lot of people to be the
center of the ear kind of heading down
towards the corner of the mouth that's
usually the general vicinity you don't
need a lot of contouring because you
have a really felt face so we're just
gonna add a tiny bit and I'm doing a
very light sweeping touch so I'm gonna
take a warmer shade and just kind of
warm up the contour we did a cooler
shade first to create create that
dimension in that shadow and then the
warmer shade just to blend it out we're
gonna go into her brows so I always
start by brushing upwards it's kind of
shows you the shape of the brow what
you're working with and what you need to
enhance so I am an old-school primer i
person so anything that just makes the
shadows stick because I like to do
makeup once and have it be stuck there
all day
ya don't have to worry about it so when
I prime I use just a flat brush put a
tiny bit of product and then I started
the lash line and then I sweep it up so
again what this does is it usually makes
the shadow stick the colors come out
stronger and then again you don't need
to touch up it helps with blending too
and fall out I find they're all matte
tones for me I love mat tones that can
really create dimension on the eyes so I
usually start with this and then build
the color build the shimmer in there and
then for my accent colors we are going
to use this palette it's got some matte
some shimmer and then my favorite little
blue yes so I always start with a crease
I find that creating dimension the eye
it just really helps me to place things
so keeping your eyes open you want to
find where your brow bone is
yours is right here says you've got
beautiful predominant brow bones some
people might have a little more
creepiness on their eyes or you might
not be able to see it depending on the
texture and just the anatomy of their I
am so I want you to feel for it so you
can always stick a brush in and right
underneath this brow bone that's where
your crease is so taking a color that's
a little bit warm which means it has
more of that like peachy tone to it and
tonight so placing it right under that
brow bone a little bit of back and forth
a little bit of circular motions this is
just going to create that nice diffused
effect
so next I'm gonna do a brow highlight
and I do like to mix so again a warmer
shade with a tiny pop and we're just
gonna go right hit that arch first and
then sweep it out again for the lid I
did want it to stand out a little bit so
we added a tiny bit of shimmer but
keeping it really natural still so as
you see I press a little bit on I tap
any excess off and then I like to turn
the brush upside down this kind of
catches the fall out so that you don't
have the product falling all over your
cheeks and I sweep upwards and then it
goes right back into the brush look how
pretty that is anytime there's a focal
point
I'll look I like to get that on there
before I finish things so what we did is
gonna start out this is um make up
forever liner so just like a dark kind
of blue she matches your trochlear
perfectly look at that so this is a
waterproof liner you can go ahead and
look up for me and when I do the
waterline I kind of just press down on
the eye tiny bit because she was
performing I want it to a little
exaggerated and then we're gonna go
underneath so with a really tiny brush
I'm going to take the blue shadow pick
it up and then I'm just
press it on press and wiggle so you can
see the difference this one's a lot
stronger because of the shadow and then
this one has the liner so now we're
going to make that pop so that's why I
did the double layer so now she has the
focal point people always ask me about
lashes so there's a lot of tricks you
can do with lashes my favorite tip is I
don't ever apply a full strip anymore
so I take my lash and I cut it up Wow
so I'm a three not girl so I like three
dots three dots three dots it bends with
your eyes so you will notice when you're
wearing them they're not as heavy the
inside doesn't bother you
yeah and you can really sometimes I'll
even take a lash and place the place
that like this one's longer on the
outside sometimes I'll put that right in
the center mmm and so I'll create my own
our own lash yeah
last couple steps so we're gonna add a
tiny bit of highlight on the inner
corner actually a face highlighter but
it's the most beautiful inner corner
highlight I'm also gonna add the same
one just to the tops of her cheekbones
you can also take a tiny bit down the
bridge of the nose and then I'm going to
apply a little bit to her Cupid's bow
and this is just a smaller blending
brush and then last but not least
because the eyes were so strong we
wanted to keep the lip a little bit more
natural it's the most beautiful like
it's a pink with a gold so it almost
reads a little peachy so for your cheeks
I'm gonna do kind of more orange tones
there you have it I love it tell us how
you got started in makeup I got started
a makeup
quite a long time ago but my first real
makeup job was at MAC Cosmetics I think
it was like 2001 maybe yeah I'm dating
myself now but that was my big start how
did you meet Demi I met Demi almost six
years ago my agent booked me that was
actually my first client that she ever
booked me with and when I said can you
fly to New York I said sure and she said
can you do this girl Demi and I said
sure and I did her and we did this
amazing red lip and you loved it and
then she was like are you available
tomorrow I said sure and the rest is
history what has been her craziest ask
of you we definitely did some crazy
looks during x-factor we were shooting
five days a week
oh yeah she had some cool outfit so a
lot of times it was just playing around
with the different outfits one time
there was this yellow eye shadow look
there was another one that was we did
this really crazy like hairstyle that
was like this doughnut roll thing and we
did a really cool winged liner and
literally right before we got up to go
she
she was like I want it thicker and drew
it in I was like alright we're doing it
thicker we did this really thick and it
was it was a crazy winged liner and I
got a lot of press and you know it is
what it is sometimes that you just kind
of go with the flow you know it's really
a collaboration I told you it yes yeah
so what has been a highlight working
with Demi I think the biggest highlight
I mean she's an amazing musician so half
the time my job is to do her makeup and
then go to a concert so I can't complain
you've worked with her for a really long
time how has her look evolved from when
you started until now we've definitely
evolved her look her eyebrows have
evolved a lot from thinner too thicker
thinner and our I think we're at a
really good place her and I trust each
other a lot so like recently her recent
album cover was a really great
breakthrough we did pretty much no
makeup yeah your tongue oh yeah and hurt
all of her freckles showed and it was
just really raw and vulnerable and it
was really amazing it's beautiful can we
expect a Jill Powell makeup line
possibly in the future I would hope so
would you guys buy it yes oh my gosh
so hopefully someday yeah it's it's in
here it just needs it to actually be
produced definitely well Jill I just
wanted to thank you so much for being
here today was how to Hollywood yeah
thank you for having me it's been fun so
if you guys have any extra questions for
Jill please leave them in the comments
down below and I'll answer them or I'll
shoot him her way if she hasn't seen
them and make sure to subscribe to
entertainment tonight's YouTube channel
and I'll see you in the next one thanks
guys bye baby
[Music]